herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
ausgabe von tv akut wie pervers ist
deutschland das ist eine frage die sich
immer wieder um willkürlich stellt wenn
man tv akut anschaut wenn man an so
berichte sieht also ich meine unsere
berichte über perverse heute bin ich mit
einem perversen verabredet er will
verständlicherweise nicht erkannt werden
deshalb haben wir ihn unkenntlich
gemacht guten tag ich hab das jetzt
einfach mal so ganz unverblümt sie
möchten nicht erkannt werden weil sie
pervers sind doch ich bin ein
sogenannter multiprocessing ich bin
total komplett pervers wenn jürgen moos
pws dann bin ich dabei und zwar mit
begeisterung beispiel beispiel ja wie
ich habe zum beispiel gerne sechs mit
frauen bin dann teilweise gelockert
dabei und was man auch vorstellen könnte
dies war sechs sondern wir mit jürgen
theiner bekannten schauspielerin dann
heute auch mit hut auf und auch so
fantasie vom juni sex mit der frau die
gern flamenco tanz in form 6 und von mir
aus
dennoch glaube ich gerne dass sie
unerkannt bleiben möchte kann die zu
spielen bin ich erkannt werden würde
fällt diese ewige heimlichtuerei nicht
schwer haben sich ständig angst davor
entdeckt zu werden
doch schrecklich jungs furchtbare angst
vor allem angst dass ich mir einen
unfall nicht als sie ins krankenhaus
kommen weil ich habe hier unter meiner
normalen kleidung habe ich eine rote
striemen unterhose an
die wohl auch in interviews hinter unten
in welchem etat sind sie denn tätig ich
hoffe dass ich jetzt nicht zu viel
verraten wenig so dass ich eine bäckerei
habe hier im wald lingen
vielen dank der offenen worte ist es
wirklich so dass unsere gesellschaft
noch nicht bereit ist für enthüllungen
dieser art sitzen die bäckerei brauchen
wir - einer bekannten ganzen gegen
führung zudem natursauerteig politik
nein das war es an vielen dank herr
braucht man
zurück ins studio